[Musique]
sur l'île de vancouver les forêts
pluviales ancien disparaissent à un
rythme inquiétant exa bri des arbres
géants dont plusieurs sont nés au moyen
âge la scientifique susan simard
professeur en écologie forestière s'est
donné comme mission de les protéger
c'est un monde de géants
des arbres majestueux couvert de mousse
certains sont millénaires
les forêts anciennes qui longe la côte
de la colombie-britannique a briqué plus
grands arbres du canada
et elles disparaissent dans le rythme et
keita
depuis le mois d'août de melgven des
militants venus de partout au canada
érigent des barrages routiers et occupe
des campements dans la région de féric
au sud de l'île de vancouver
ils veulent empêcher la société
forestière tir jones de coupe est l'une
des dernières forêts anciennes de l'île
plus de 1100 manifestants ont été
arrêtés à ce jour par la gendarmerie
royale du canada ce serait le plus grand
mouvement de désobéissance civile dans
l'histoire du pays
[Musique]
ce matin une scientifique prend la route
pour rejoindre les manifestants
de fortes pluies s'abattent sur la
région mais lui en faut bien plus pour
s'arrêter
certains vont penser que ce n'est pas ma
place comme chercheuse suzanne timmins
et professeur à l'université de la
colombie britannique
c'est une véritable vedette de
l'écologie forestière
une pionnière qui a contribué à
découvrir comment les arbres
communiquent entre eux nous sommes dans
une crise climatique dans une crise de
biodiversité
j'ai des connaissances qui peuvent nous
aider
qu'est ce que j'ai à perdre au mouvement
en travers d'une route forestière qui
crèvent dans la montagne les
manifestants viennent diriger un
campement pour bloquer le passage des
camions et de la machinerie
juste derrière le campement improvisé
deux jeunes femmes se sont barricadés
dans une voiture
si la police tente de les déloger elles
passeront leurs bras à travers un trou
dans la carrosserie et s'enchaîneront au
sol
quelques kilomètres plus loin le calme
règne
susan se marre nous amène jusqu'à y
d'une grosse une forêt qui n'est pas
encore dans la mire de l'industrie
forestière
dans une forêt comme celle ci c'est
incroyable il ne renie brune quand on
inspire on inhale l'autre tombent des
arbres là est rempli d'humilité nous
aussi nous sommes emplis d'eau
on est donc connectés d'une certaine
façon à ces arbres et à cette fois
dans les forêts pluviales de la colombie
britannique
les sapins de douglas et les proches se
mêle au dessus à géant des colosses qui
font jusqu'à 6 mètres de diamètre
c'est sur leur bois dur et dense que ces
bâtis l'économie de la province
les activités des sociétés forestières
se sont intensifiées à partir des années
l'industrie convoitent les forêts
anciennes parce que les vieux arbres
sont énormément de valeur lorsqu'on les
coupes pour en faire des 2 par 4 ou
d'autres matériaux comme des bardeaux
schengen
ferry quick est un bassin versant situé
entre les villages de porquerolles
freins et les coïts chan ils se trouvent
sur le territoire de la première nation
patxi date c'est le dernier bassin
versant qui n'a pas encore été coupée
j'appelle la dernière larmes du sud de
l'île de vancouver
selon un rapport publié en 2020 par
trois scientifiques indépendants - 2 3 %
des forêts pluviales son ancien de la
colombie britannique aurait échappé à
l'industrie forestière jusqu'à
maintenant
pourtant aux dires du gouvernement 26 %
des forêts de la province serait peuplé
d'arbres aux anciens
c'est parce que le gouvernement tient
compte des forêts qui se trouvent dans
les marais au sommet des montagnes il
met tous ensemble et se dire et ça fait
26 % mais certains de ces arbres ne font
même pas un mètre et demi
quand les gens pensent ou forêts
anciennes il pense à ces arbres
majestueux qui absorbe et tonnes de
carbone et qui sont essentiels à la
biodiversité c'est celle là qu'il faut
protéger et dont il reste seulement 3%
en juin 2021 le gouvernement de john key
à annoncé un moratoire de deux ans sur
l'exploitation forestière à faire un
cric mais tout autour les coupables en
continu
les manifestants ne décolère pas il
demande maintenant la protection
perpétuelle de toutes les forêts
anciennes de la province
ce n'est pas la première guerre dans les
bois a éclaté dans la région en 1993
près de 900 manifestants avaient été
arrêtés ils s'opposaient à
l'exploitation forestière dans l'abbaye
au kwat près de deux fils aux
retraites on ne réussit à protéger de
petites parcelles quelques bassins
versants n'est pas ce
week end est l'une des
environnementalistes les plus connus de
la colombie britannique
elle a participé aux manifestations de
la baie clio quoi tu
commentes est ce que les choses ont
évolué depuis
très très peu je pense même qu'on a
reculé au cours des 20 dernières années
à 80 ans elle s'implique du mieux
qu'elle peut afrique
on se bat pour des restes en registré
veut tout prendre le gouvernement lui a
donné carte blanche le benfica demain
les manifestants plus aujourd'hui avec
une nouvelle arme la séance
susan se meurt et quelques collègues ont
recensé les attributs écologique de la
forêt de faire un cric
la quantité de carbone stockée dans ces
arbres est évalué à 1300 tonnes par
hectare c'est plus que la forêt
amazonienne
les arbres fixe dioxyde de carbone qui
se trouvent dans l'atmosphère il le
stock dans leur tronc leurs branches et
leurs racines
quand on coupe la forêt jusqu'à 65% du
carbone retourne à l'atmosphère en moins
d'une année contribuant changement
climatique
[Musique]
mais résidus de coupe qui jonchent le
sol sont brûlés le carbone stocké sous
le sol dans les racines ou les
champignons se décompose et s'évapore
beaucoup d'arbres sont transformés en
produits de courte vie comme le papy
gynéco du papier il se transforme en co2
à l'intérieur d'un an ou à peine plus
sioux
seulement une fraction du carbone
restent stockées à l'intérieur du bois
plusieurs années après la coupe dans des
matériaux de construction par exemple
après une coupe à blanc les arbres
replantés par l'industrie n'arrive pas à
capter autant de carbone que les forêts
anciennes
on replante unis deux espèces ce sont
des forêts simplifiée
en plus on les laisse pousser seulement
50 ou 60 ans avant de découper des
princes en moyenne elles accumulent
seulement le tiers du carbone que les
forêts anciennes peuvent stocker
les feux de forêt qui ont fait rage
l'été dernier en colombie britannique et
les températures records alimente la
ferveur de ceux qui se battent pour la
conservation de la forêt
[Musique]
il n'y aura pas de faim aujourd'hui
parce qu'il pleut à boire debout
mais l'été avec le réchauffement
climatique les risques augmentent les
forêts anciennes sont beaucoup moins
inflammables que les jeunes forêts
les vieux arbres en plus de cire et de
cuticules protectrice sur leurs épines
ils ont des écorces épaisse qui les
protègent contre le feu quentin fût-ce
au sauvetage sur un vaste territoire et
qu'il arrive une vieille forêt il
s'essouffle au contraire quand il arrive
sur une plantation récente surtout une
monoculture il se répand à toute vitesse
soudainement croit aussi que les
coupables en ont un lien direct avec les
inondations dévastatrices et les
glissements terrain subi cette année en
colombie britannique
les forêts anciennes sont d'immenses
éponge qui tempère le débit des eaux
leurs racines immense joue un rôle
essentiel à la stabilité des sols
[Musique]
a fait inscrire les policiers de la grc
commencé à démanteler les barrages qui
bloquent la route forestière
un peu plus loin ils ont démonté un
campement appelé watford quelques
manifestants ont été arrêtés puis
relâchés
lightning bolt c'est son nom d'emprunt
en fait partie igo
[Musique]
le 2 novembre dernier quelques jours
après notre passage à ferry creek le
gouvernement de la colombie britannique
a annoncé son intention d'élargir le
moratoire sur la coupe des forêts
anciennes au delà de féric il veut
suspendre pour deux ans l'exploitation
de 3,6 millions d'hectares dans la
province cela représente environ le
tiers des forêts à risque
'l'annonce n'a pas apaisé les
manifestants car suspendre
l'exploitation ne veut pas dire protéger
la forêt à jamais
par ailleurs les moratoires seront
appliquées seulement lorsque les
communautés autochtones concernées
auront donné leur accord
certaines premières nations sont en
faveur de la conservation mais d'autres
veulent exploiter la forêt à leur façon
à faire un cric les patchs d'adp
reçoivent des bénéfices importantes
l'exploitation forestière il possède des
droits de coupe travaille en partenariat
avec l'industrie et opèrent leur propre
syrie
leur chef jeff jones a refusé nous
accorder une entrevue il nous a transmis
cette déclaration au nom des pâtis date
et de deux premières nations voisines
dorénavant nos premières nations
prendront les décisions concernant notre
territoire notre eau et nos ressources
dans le meilleur est elle un présent et
futur des études à deux ou à quatre et
les batizado
vikitsreth band crois qu'elle est patxi
date les autres premières nations
pourraient réorienter leurs économies si
seulement on leur en donner les moyens
le potentiel touristique est énorme
les derniers grands arbres ont beaucoup
plus de valeur de bouc a coupé parce que
ce sont eux qui vont amener des
visiteurs
mais pour faire cette transition vers
l'écotourisme
les communautés ont besoin d'appui il
faut du temps et des investissements
soudain c'est marc est sensible aux
droits des autochtones eux seuls peuvent
déterminer leur avenir mais pour elle la
conservation des forêts anciennes et
dans l'intérêt de tous
ces forêts n'ont pas de prix
si on les coupe c'est notre survie qui
est en jeu
[Musique]
mon